when I was 29 years old in January of
2000 my mother unfortunately died in an
accident down in Costa Rica she drowned
on a river that they really shouldn't
have been on it was swollen with rains
and the company that they had gone with
already had a lot of safety violations
and I've talked about this in another
video so I'm not going to go into the
details of her death her grieving or the
funeral and all the other stuff that was
associated with it one of the things
that I was thinking about lately because
I was taking a drive down to Indiana and
I was thinking about this actually as I
was going through Chicago
and seeing the turn for Highway 57
Interstate Highway 57 which goes all the
way down to well it goes down to
Carbondale Illinois and then goes well
past it as well uh that was where I
would take it to was the drives that I
had to take going back and forth between
the Milwaukee area specifically the
suburb of Brookfield where my mother had
recently purchased a house she'd moved
from Menomonee Falls where she'd been
living for about 10 years or so to
Brookfield into a different house a
newer house a nicer house in a uh you
know kind of ritzy subdivision and of
course it was mortgaged to the hilt you
know she had bought it with some some
proceeds and put it down payment and
then it was you know when we sold it we
basically didn't make any money but
in order to handle her estate we had to
meet with these lawyers and they were
also in Brookfield and when I say we I
mean my myself and my sister who was
pregnant at the time and really kind of
a mess and she had a fiance who she did
later marry of course and then you know
had a child with and and would divorce
later and I had a girlfriend at the time
as well in graduate school and so for a
little while it was all of us putting
our heads together and I had some
support from family as well who'd shown
up and you know but most of the
long-term stuff having to do with being
an executor of the estate fell to me
and so I was down in Carbondale Illinois
at the time at Southern Illinois
University Carbondale I was in graduate
school and as a matter of fact I would
have been in my PhD program I was just
uh getting to teach one of my own
classes that was at a higher level I
taught to ethics classes prior to that
and now I was teaching philosophy of
politics Law And Justice which was kind
of a big deal and getting ready to like
you know start eventually working on my
dissertation and then my my mom dies and
there are Myriad details that have to be
handled in terms of an estate and
sometimes you might hear of the the
death tax or the estate tax well because
she owned this house which was quite
valuable but which was largely debt she
was across the line just across the line
for having to file estate tax right and
she wouldn't actually have to pay any
but she had to file or her estate had to
file so that meant I had to go up and
meet with these lawyers you know for a
while it was like once every two or
three weeks
we had to sell the house we had to do
all sorts of things consolidate bank
accounts you know there was lots and
lots and lots of business to to handle
and to transact and you know I wasn't
particularly experienced in this sort of
thing and I was dealing with with the
grief and school and all of these sort
of matters
in any case I would have to make this
drive in order to get up there from
Carbondale all the way up through
Chicago to Milwaukee and then to
Brookfield and then you know be there
for a certain amount of time and then
drive back down again and it's that
drive that I was thinking about and I
wanted to tell you about and some of
this is going to be geographical and
some of it it's going to be just
memories of things and you know sort of
reminiscing about it
and do remember that we're talking about
a time more than 20 years ago so you
know cars are different now the ways in
which we go about things is quite
different now and
um you know some of this will be like
back in my day but a lot of it might be
of interest to people so you know if you
if you look at the map to go from
Carbondale Illinois
up to Brookfield Wisconsin you know if
you make really really good time maybe a
seven hour trip it could take you longer
depending on if you get caught in
traffic jams you can't really easily
avoid going through Chicago I mean you
could take alternate routes but then you
would be on much slower highways that
are not the interstate and that go you
know roughly up the the you know central
part of Illinois stopping everywhere
that would take even
longer so you know you would get on the
road and uh
cut across going east until you hit
Highway 57 and then it's a long long
drive up 57 to get to Chicago and so you
know you'd hit various towns along the
way where you could stop and get gas or
get something to eat or pick up a snack
or just get out and stretch your legs
but you know once you got out of
Southern Illinois
57 is it's one of those roads there's
many roads like this in the United
States it's one of those roads that's
kind of boring right it's it's fairly
flat in much of Central and Northern
Illinois
lots and lots of fields but you know
you've seen one field you kind of seen
most of them I won't say that you've
seen all of them and so
you get on the road and you would
anticipate all right I'm gonna have to
like go for a while and you know it's a
long long drive so it's not you know
you're not looking forward to spending
uh you know any more time than you have
to on the road I should preface
something too I had a car so before my
mother died
um I'd had a car before when I was in
undergraduate and then shortly after
coming here to Milwaukee I was in a
terrible accident it got totaled and
then I didn't have another car until
after my mother died and she had a
Chrysler Sebring convertible which she'd
you know recently purchased
and it wasn't a bad car it was kind of
sporty you know pretty fast a lot of
good pickup to it
being a convertible wasn't great because
a lot of the driving I was doing was in
the winter time so it could get kind of
kind of chilly at times and
um you know since I had to take care of
the estate and we knew where I was going
to be you know traversing back and forth
and it was part of the estate uh my
sister and I and the lawyers decided I
would I would get that later on actually
my sister and I would swap cars after
the estate was being handled because she
wanted the Sebring but I had it as a
resource for these long drives so anyway
I get in the Sebring get on 57 start
heading north and now it's like you know
acres and Acres of cornfield broken up
by exits here and there and places where
you could turn off and I actually knew
the route already pretty well because
since I didn't have a car before you
know my mother died if I wanted to come
up here to Milwaukee for you know
Vacations or I actually had a girlfriend
here in Milwaukee for a while I would
take the Greyhound bus and the Greyhound
bus takes exactly the same route
but not quite so quick and it stops all
sorts of places actually the very first
stop for the Greyhound bus after
Carbondale is Marion if you know
anything about that town it's mostly
associated with the federal prison which
is there where you know for example John
Gotti was was kept and uh you know he'd
always have a couple prisoners who were
on furlough getting on the bus usually
getting themselves in trouble getting
kicked off the bus by the time that we
got up to say Effingham you know the bus
would pull over and the state troopers
would come and pull them off so I I was
pretty accustomed to this route
and I would just get on the road and you
know I would make sure I was gassed up
if it was bad weather I try to make sure
the windshields were as clear as
possible one of the things you do when
you stop at a gas station is you clean
your windows right you get in you dip
into that that slosh that they have
which might be wiper fluid or it might
just be water it might be who knows what
sometimes it smells a little off and you
you know rub it across your windows and
then use the squeegee to clean it off
and you know you just do all these sorts
of things you gas up get something get
some snacks you know like beef jerky or
candy bars or something like that get
yourself a coffee maybe get yourself a
Coke some water and then you head out
and you try to make as many miles as you
can before you have to stop again and
you know sometimes it can be interesting
to see what's going on you know if
you've got a fast car you can pass
people up you got to watch out for the
cops of course you don't want to get
pulled over and get a ticket because
that that's expensive and it also cuts
into your time but you know you find
some some every once in a while there
there'd actually be like other people
that were into you know making good time
and you follow them you can tell that
they're you know passing at the right
time and you'd be almost like a little
Convoy and one of the things that I
would do
that would help me you know kill the
time was to listen to the radio and
so you know you'd listen to radio
stations and they play different kinds
of music or you listen to some you know
some NPR some national public radio and
they'd have interesting shows or you
know you flip to the am band and you
might hear something that could be kind
of interesting depending on the time of
day or night and I would do some of this
driving at night in fact you know
now that I recall it wasn't always
during the bright lights of the day or
the overcast you know rainy sky
sometimes I would get on the road at
night because I knew that was the best
time to make good time on the road but
then you you know you get tired you get
a little Punchy you got to listen to to
stuff to help keep your mind active but
the car also had a CD player and this is
back when it was quite common to listen
to our music on compact discs this is
before well I think there are probably
some You Know MP3 players out there at
the time but I didn't have that sort of
technology and
so compact discs were the way to go and
you know I was listening to a wide
variety of stuff I remember you know for
example listening to The Offspring
because I had a few of their CDs and I
also remember listening to Blood Sweat
and Tears I had a CD of them and you
know every once in a while I I was
already kind of emotional and some of
the songs would remind me of my dad who
had passed away years and years and
years before that when I was only 11 and
you know I listened to other things as
well I had kind of you know a nice CD
collection so a lot of grunge stuff at
the time some metal stuff some
alternative stuff some folk and and
whatever you know you you want to call
that 1970s mix of uh different genres of
music that we'd listen to and
you put a CD in and that would help the
the miles go away and sometimes you had
to watch out for zoning out you know you
would be listening to something and your
eyes are kind of looking at what you're
doing and you're you know your muscle
memory of the car is handling things and
suddenly you realize you've gone 50
miles and you can't remember
any of it that's a little scary when
that happens so anyway you've got this
long long stretch of 57 that's a bit
boring you know you just want to try to
get through it as much as possible and
then you start getting to the outskirts
of what we call Chicagoland right
Chicago is a major
metropolitan area in the United States
with the biggest city in the Midwest and
it's vast you know and it's unavoidable
too if you're trying to get to the
Milwaukee area unless you want to do a
real detour around so the only ways
through Chicago are to make it through
and you know there's various routes that
you can take with the interstate I would
typically take uh Interstate 94 or this
Loop 294 that goes out around the
suburbs it's a bypass at that time it
didn't really make sense for me to try
to take the Skyway 90. although the
Skyway is pretty cool and all of these
you know Illinois has tolls right so you
got to pay money especially if you're on
294. and this is before like Easy Pass
OR iPass or any of these electronic
things you actually had to have money
like physical money that you could
either like hand to somebody in the toll
booth and then they'd give you change
back or you had to have change and you
throw it into this bucket and it would
get all you know tabulated and fall down
in there and like computers would chart
it and then it would like lift the toll
thing then you could get on your way and
that would slow you down a good bit
nowadays with you know all these
electronic things you can just like roll
through
that wasn't the case in the past and
that's you know that's what we grew up
with and that that's just the way it was
so anyway you start rolling in and you
get to these places like you know
Kankakee and Joliet you know you're
making your way through on Highway 57
then eventually you get to where 57
intersects with 80 94. and now you know
you you try to make as good time as you
can and you're zooming through this city
oftentimes I would start like in the
afternoon and I'd be hitting Chicago at
night everything would be dark except
for all the lights everywhere and there
were you know
sometimes traffic jams sometimes you'd
make it through okay and if you were
making it through okay one of the
peculiarities of Chicago traffic at that
time and still going on to the present
is you know
within the city limits even on the
interstate your speed limit is 55 miles
an hour
that's not how Chicago people drive if
you're on the interstate and traffic is
moving
smoothly you're going about 80 miles an
hour May if you're driving 70 which is
way over the speed limit you have people
passing you constantly some of them
going 90 miles an hour right and it's
not just the cars even the trucks the
big semis are barreling through and they
do this in construction zones they do
this everywhere else there's always
construction zones on the interstate in
in Chicago as well so you make it up
through Chicago you're on the South Side
maybe you if you take 294 you go through
the suburbs and then you pass O'Hare and
now you're on the North side if you're
taking 94 you you go through the loop
and then you make it all the way up to
the point where you need to be and
um you know then you're on the North
side and you get you know you start
seeing these different Oasis that you
can stop at and it's you know it's it's
a lot more exciting being in Chicago but
by that time you're getting pretty
fatigued right you've been dry driving
for at least five hours and so then you
know you make it through and now you you
know you're on the way to Wisconsin and
things start getting a little bit you
know sparser there's certain roads like
you know that I I remember passing all
the time uh Tui for example there there
was a girl who I went to uh college with
who had that last name and I always
wondered if she was like you know
somehow associated with that you get
these Idol thoughts going through your
head and then suddenly your your past
Waukegan and you're hitting the state
border and now you're on your way to
Milwaukee and you pass Kenosha and you
passed Racine and the exits for them
maybe you stop there and then you get to
Milwaukee and then taking Milwaukee 94
swings way out you know going it would
go all the way past Madison and to the
edge of the state I only had to go a
short way after that that
to get off in Brookfield and then make
my way you know maybe 10 minutes to the
subdivision where my my mom had her
house and then I would stay there for
however long I needed to while I did
things with the lawyers and you know
catch up with a few of my friends who
are still in town and then I would have
to get back on the road and do the whole
thing in reverse
and I do want to mention one other thing
about that so you know you you get
yourself out of Milwaukee go down
through Chicago now you're pretty fresh
as you're doing that right and
oftentimes like I said I would do that
in the middle of the night so that I
could avoid the traffic in Chicago
but now you've got that long stretch of
57 ahead of you
the boring Flats nothing really there
stretch until you get into Southern
Illinois and you start having Hills and
more interesting terrain and then you're
on your way back home and I I will
mention this to to bring this to a close
so you know it was a rough time in my
life you know I lost my mom my dad was
long gone
a lot of grieving going on a lot of
processing of feelings you know I was in
graduate school so I had a lot uh on my
mind with with that as well what am I
going to do for my dissertation
and
one of the Comforts that I would take
was finding places that I did want to
stop you know not just to get gas but
for a decent meal
and I don't remember where this was
along 57 what exit what town but there
was a small little town and they had a
A-Frame
um restaurant you know the sort of high
roof uh kind of construction and it was
called Amish something but I don't think
there were any Amish people involved it
was just sort of a selling point and I
stopped there enough times that the wait
staff got to you know recognize me when
I'd come in and I'd have like a book
that I was I was going to read and I
would sit there and I would get a Coke a
water a patty melt fries and chili and
occasionally I'd get dessert but most
the time not right depending on what
they they had if they had a good pie or
something and I would sit there and you
know kind of decompress from the road
and dip my fries into the chili which is
one of the ways I like to have that
stuff and eat that have the patty melt
which is you know rye bread with a Patty
and cheese and onions on top of that and
I would just sort of like you know
sometimes I wouldn't even read the book
I would just sort of like think to
myself about what I was doing and what
was going on and just sort of process
I wasn't rolling you know anymore I mean
some of these drives you get to the
point with these older cars where even
after you get out you feel like you're
still moving you feel like you're still
bouncing around a little bit and that's
that's what I would feel as I was doing
that I don't remember exactly where that
was like I said it was about two hours
from Carbondale so it was a convenient
spot for me to stop on the way down not
generally on the way up but I I don't
know how many times I made those trips
but it certainly was a lot and you know
how many hours how many days did I spend
on the road doing that I don't have a
clue I you know but it happened it was a
significant part of what I had to go
through and I was just reminded of that
like I said this last weekend when I
drove down to Indiana and I was on 94
and I saw the turn off for 57 and I
thought to myself thank goodness I don't
have to do that anymore so that's the
story of that long lonely Trek that I
had to do over and over and over again
for about close to a year maybe even a
year and a half